the jurgen experience just wanted to go
home i wanted my daughter
to [ __ ] see the things i saw as a kid
not north jersey type [ __ ]
but i wanna did you see that [ __ ]
special on uh
that amusement park when we were kids
from verona new jersey what's the name
action park no they ended up calling it
class action park
that's dope you got happening what
happened was that
yeah every time you win there they take
you on a neck brace [ __ ] it when you
were a kid doug please jamie if you find
anything a trailer dude i was at a
[ __ ] one of those fairs
pull up in a parking lot look at this
[ __ ] when we were kids you know jesus
christ you're flying down these things
how many kids got broken legs oh my god
every time you went there if you went
with eight kids somebody was going about
it's dangerous
new jersey or burning new york oh my god
people are jumping off cliffs
whoa you could
drive that [ __ ] race cars everything
you could what is this bungee jumping
this was the 70s with the class action
pool that was like palisade amusement
park it's a it's a pool that's like a
big cops probe look at this [ __ ] park
accident so people just got in accidents
all the time oh every other weekend look
at it
but is that okay here's the question
when i was a kid i didn't go out to play
i won't have to die big difference okay
these little [ __ ] half of fruitcakes
today they want to play i went out to
die remember you hugged your mother and
[ __ ] like you hugged the good mom i
don't know we're gonna go rob a train i
don't know what's gonna happen but look
at this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is so ridiculous
new york had a ton of these when we were
kids from tuxedo new york
all the way down
oh my god
that's hilarious
action park you got to watch the doc why
was this so here's the question if you
could go like if you guys are doing like
bmx flips you know guys are practicing
for those things how many of those guys
get hurt
a lot right
how often they get hurt
well why is it okay if they get hurt but
it's not okay if you go to a park where
you're
reasonably certain you have a good
chance of getting hurt
like if if it's basically people paying
to have the same kind of risk factor as
you would do if you were doing something
else crazy
that's totally okay like why can't you
you know what i'm saying like you can
get a bmx bike there can be a ramp
people know you're gonna jump it
everybody knows that's fine but
that what is that more of a commitment
because you went you got a helmet you
got a bike and you got the whole thing
instead of just going to this place
you this should be a place where it's
[ __ ] risky
right this should be a like if somebody
had
if you had a lock
down
solid contract where no matter what
happened to you you you couldn't sue
them they could make a place like that
again
but i don't think they would ever be
able to hold you gotta watch the
documentary
i watched it i remember watching it it's
tremendous but is it is it negligence
yes oh if i remember correctly there's a
lot of
people telling them you can't do this
for kids and people like give a [ __ ]
it's the 80s we're doing coke we're
making money have fun but they're
jumping off cliffs like that thing like
the fact that they had a cliff dive
like that's just crazy
they built a cliff dive
and you pa people could just jump like
if you hit
if you're drive jumping off of this is
the big thing that they had remember
the bridge where everybody would like
get drunk and jump off of and people
were getting hurt they're landing on
each other all the time oh of course
look at that i can imagine that they
would i imagine people landed on each
other on purpose well i think that's a
part of it because they would cheer it'd
be like you're the you're the man for
the five minutes of the summer day
that's a great way to break your neck
someone is just flying and landing on
you that is watch the doctor great way
to break your neck
it's really good i think there's even a
fictionalized version that johnny
knoxville made that's why he popped up
in that thing and i don't remember what
that's called
you know these places and it was the 70s
late 70s early 80s 70s i don't think the
insurance regulations were as strict as
they are today
like they didn't have a [ __ ] idea
open up a park yeah whatever just give
me 900 a month send this a check on the
first
they probably didn't have the kind of
they don't know what kind of places is
that seaside you know it's nice couple
little swings here's a question